we're gonna do a draft chris and
you're not ready for it which makes it
even better because that makes me more
likely to win this is a simple one i'll
give you the first pick defining moments
from super bowl 54 defining moments
you can get you get to go first okay i
mean the the you know third and fifteen
that's the defining moment that's where
i gotta start i mean that was the
biggest play of the game that defines
the kansas city chiefs defines patrick
mahomes i mean that play alone if it
doesn't happen right there we're going
oh my gosh it's third and 15 with this
great pass rush of the 49ers they're
screwed here this is going to be tough i
know he overcame these type of things
against the texans and the titans but
this is the 49ers oh not so fast they
did you know they they just continue to
defy the odds and what i saw what was
the probability 90
96 win probability at that point
for the san francisco 49ers well that's
why analytics don't really always match
up because there's not a you know
there's this is patrick mahomes and it's
just the not the same when he's got the
ball still and that to me is the
defining moment really in a microcosm is
just the chiefs all together in the
mahomes era hey uh the the and that's
the obvious number one pick 2-3
jet chip wasp it's the new 65 toss power
trap a play suggested by patrick mahomes
approved by andy reid they used it it
worked it it woke up the chiefs out of
three and a half quarters of doldrums
all right for me it's the damian
williams go ahead touchdown it has to be
third and goal from the five we're
talking the press box what are they
gonna do here if they don't get it going
forward on fourth down makes the catch i
thought it wasn't even close i thought
he was out inside the one from the other
end of the field in the press box and
that ball gets reached across the foot
is out and i'm telling you chris
whatever the ruling on the field was
that was the ruling that was going to be
upheld via replay review not enough
evidence to overturn a ruling that the
ball wasn't across
not enough to overturn a ruling that it
was a cross automatic review because the
ruling on the field was a touchdown and
the touchdown is upheld and the chiefs
take the lead right that was the moment
because let me tell you if that ball is
short you got a heck of a decision to
make at fourth and goal from maybe the
one inch line down three points late in
the fourth quarter yeah yeah i mean
you're right mike that was a huge play
and and defining in the fact that again
andy reed had another cool little
wrinkle right to just keep the 49ers off
balance kind of moving mahomes ooh it's
a little boot he's kind of you know play
action oh throw it over they're good
they don't know which way to go it's
just great to game plan design again by
breed too which makes a game defining
andy reid defining all of those things
he had so many little trick plays just
like that that used the aggression of
the 49ers defense and their team's speed
against them uh i'm gonna go back to
another mahomes pass i'm gonna go to the
watkins second and seven 38-yard gain
you know yeah it sets up the touchdown
you're talking about but again the
game's 20 to 17. and yes the the chiefs
had the great ride the great drive
before that but you're going man can
they drive down again and really score a
touchdown on this great 49ers defense
and knock it in and put it in the end
zone and when it became this play was
second and seven and him throwing down
the right sideline that's when you went
oh wow
wait
forget this yeah can they go down and
score a touchdown yes they can they're
down there they're rolling momentum's
totally on their side and the 49ers got
to be scared to death because here we go
kansas city chiefs and as much as the
third and 15 got them jump started i
feel like this play was like
the
oh
now it was like the the stamp of
confidence like oh we're here and we're
coming to win this thing right now
uh just a great throw great job by sammy
watkins release off the line of
scrimmage and a huge play for the chiefs
and here's another one that we haven't
discussed much it came with 9 47 to play
as the 49ers were facing third and 14
from their own 34.
jimmy garoppolo scrambles toward the
sideline and he got blown up sir right
at the sideline he got thrown hard out
of bounds and
that's one of those where in the past
we've seen the flag come out and you saw
the reaction of the bodies around it
because it was on the 49er sideline
where everybody's just kind of jumping
up and down waiting for the flag and i'm
looking around is there a yellow hanky
flying straight up in the air because i
wouldn't have been surprised if there
was a penalty flag called it would have
given the 49ers a fresh set of downs
from their own 49
with
about 9 45 left to play
changes everything at that point if that
flag comes out and i'm not saying it was
right i'm not saying it was wrong
there's a range of discretion that the
officials have and if someone would have
thrown that flag i don't think people
would have lost their minds they didn't
and people didn't lose their minds about
that either but it could have gone
either way that's a defining moment
because if they get the 15 yards and the
fresh set of downs it becomes a lot
harder for the chiefs to erase the
10-point deficit yeah that i mean it was
big you're right i mean that could have
been a game-changing moment play
whatever it is um
just because i didn't know we were doing
this draft and um i didn't know it that
was an average pick i've seen better
there was more defining moments like
that um all right go ahead and give me
one give me one um i'm going to the you
know what do they say the same church
different pew a little bit here but i'm
gonna go that
that second and nine okay our second and
five all right the the 49ers ran the
ball for five yards up the middle chris
jones batting the ball down on second
and five to get the 49ers in a third
down must-pass situation all right where
the the chiefs are very good when
spagnilla knows you're gonna throw the
ball and he can do these creative
coverages and on the back end but this
was second and five and shanahan had
george kittle wide open through a great
little game design play a play really
like the chiefs run a whole lot and
kittle was wide open over the middle but
chris jones
his awareness one of the best defensive
players in football made a number of big
plays in the game and this was about his
second or third big batted pass
that to me was a huge moment in the
football game because it went back to
what we've said oh jones gets that
now it's third down they got to throw
the ball with jimmy garoppolo and we
know that's not necessarily the strength
of the 49ers and it played into one of
the strengths of the chiefs which is you
know creative third down pass coverage
defense
next one for me is a a penalty that was
called and it wasn't controversial it
was fairly clear but it was a huge
moment for the chiefs after the 44-yard
gain on third and 15. it was first and
ten on the san francisco 21 yeah right
first down incomplete second down
incomplete it's third and 10 from the
21. they're still down
10 points they fail there and it's a
three-pointer
and maybe it's 20 20 late not 24 20. the
throw to travis kelsey in the end zone i
don't know what the hell tarvarius moore
was thinking i don't know what he was
doing you know they had done a pretty
good job most of the night of containing
travis kelsey but moore just lays all
over him obvious defensive pass
interference like play the ball man the
ball's there what are you doing
his back was to the ball yeah and he
just kind of threw himself into kelsey
and then he was arguing afterward like
dude
you wiped him out
what are you thinking of course it's a
foul he lays all over him knocks him
down like if you just turn he could i
mean look if if he just turns his head
around the ball's there yeah he could
have intercepted it for crying out loud
no so yeah you're right
the guy was a hero temporarily for
making a pick but i don't know what kind
of technique that is is that the kind of
technique they're teaching those
defensive backs maybe robert salas
shouldn't be on the short list of head
coaching candidates for next year well
you know it's one of those things yes
some defensive backs right now are
taught to turn into the receiver and
play his hands and i can't stand that
you're for this point you're right i
mean you know with a lot of dbs have
lost their ability to play the ball
and that's where it's annoying because
you're right that would have been an
interception if he's just playing the
ball like a receiver running back
turning whatever it was mahomes threw a
careful pass there but also threw the
ball careful because he knew the guy's
back was turned and that's where mahomes
is next level and you're right moore
makes no play on the ball and then just
runs right into kelsey but uh that was
that was a big moment you're right that
we've kind of forgotten about that again
took the pressure off the chiefs a
little bit to go oh here you go first
and goal with the one you know and now
it it it set itself up for andy reid
dialing up a great creative game plan
design play which you know he had a lot
of them in the bag two weeks of
preparation he had a lot of different
ways to get two and three and one yards
when he needed it and uh that that's
kudos to andy reed right there with
great game planning
all right uh let's take a quick look at
what we have here for the picks for the
top moments the defining moments of
super bowl 54.
i've got the oh let's go with sims you
had the first pick the third and 15 play
2-3 jet chip wasp the sami watkins
38-yard reception when he got behind
richard sherman and chris jones batting
down the pass
uh key moment in the fourth quarter i
got the damien williams go ahead
touchdown third and five where he could
have been in he could have not been in
garoppolo hit hard out of bounds with no
penalty and then the pr the pi call on
the 49ers defensive back to various more
that set up the touchdown that made it
20 to 17.
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports